déjà déjà moi je regrette que enora n'y
soit pas là elle m'a dit si chiches ya
un homme
je viens donc voilà je suis venu parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas être là ce soir
et oui pas être là ce soir mais mes
voulu vous avez un message à faire
passer c'est votre feu serait parti avec
elle non c'est vrai c'est votre fils de
flynn aura ouais vraiment et bons
peuvent on peut organiser un jeu vous le
dire mais attendez donc je sais rien à
faire on l'appelle elle vient vous
revenez une autre fois on organise
qu'est ce que vous voudriez lui dira il
aura réussi pour la drague et ben voilà
pour lui dire voilà va regarder
l'émission alesi et nora site est une
vraie femme
tiens c'est tout c'est que dit ou un
autre truc oskola des séries je veux
pécho une aura 2 m
il n'aura si tu m'écoutes moi j'ai
craqué sur toi tu es belle fais-tu et
pétillante
moi j'en suis vraiment de pénétrer ton
esprit non mais l'esprit pénétrer son
esprit de la radio parce que non parce
qu'elle est intellectuellement elle est
très forte elle a beaucoup de répartie
et donc moi ça me plaît c'est concours
intellectuelle d'accord alors enora
voilà si vous nous regardez et doha
sachez que voilà votre esprit sera
bientôt pénétrer